is this really a concern to you what
elon musk is talking about meaning so do
you think this is so serious where there
should be a campaign to inspire folks to
have more kids or do you think this is a
do you think this is a financial reason
why people are not having more kids do
you think this is a
responsibility i don't want to have more
kids what do you think this is
well there already is a campaign
just look at china china had a one-child
policy for how many decades and now
they're encouraging
more than i think you're allowed to have
up to three kids in china and the laptop
their biggest exactly so china has 1.3
billion people and they've been limiting
the supply of kids supply and demand
economics and there's basically their
what how what's the average age of
people in china
india is way younger than them so now
they're basically encrypted appropriate
procreate and they can't get the people
to do it because they're like i want to
make sure that i've got the financial
wherewithal and i only think that i have
that for one child and a lot of
americans
who are of a younger age
and see housing prices as being off the
rails and the ability to i mean
if you've got the if you've got the
means if you've got the wherewithal fine
but a lot of people are like you know
what i can only really afford
to bring up one kid yeah i mean i can't
move too is there anything wrong with
that is there anything wrong with that
with that thinking with that thinking no
no okay perfectly logical i'm with that
as well because i don't think you ought
to have more kids if you can't afford to
have more
but i also think if you have the money
and the resources i think you ought to
consider having two three four five six
seven eight kids okay think about that
yeah okay 10 12 14 i also think there is
going to be a millennial baby boom
because you know millennials are are
waiting longer to have kids you a
generation ago you would have kids at
age 21 22 25. all right okay we're not
we're gonna have we're gonna have to go
now millennials will wait till 30 35
yeah but that by definition that means
that you can't have as many
so okay let's let's go ahead and still
have two three i mean it doesn't have to
be limited by one but the economy has to
be able to lift everybody up right now
and the way that we've been forming
economic
policy in this country you're going
backwards you're basically saying it's
the economy stupid it is the economy
stupid there we go danielle and i agree
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye
[Music]